make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we're jumping into Thanos
imperative part for part patro and uh
yes so we continue on our journey with
the cancerverse and everything now
here's a cool thing this picks up in in
the main Marvel Universe which is
actually where Marvel and all his forces
are at and assume joins up with with
them essentially like grabbing a Morita
November day Morita is one of many
people they think are the avatar of
death right and so at this point it's
you know tell us what's going on
give us your anomaly right and that's
the idea here is that those individuals
who were either outside the space-time
continuum meaning they're not supposed
to be in this universe because they come
from a different universe or something
like that
or individuals who have been touched by
death and returned or considered to have
anomalies these these sort of homing
beacons to a degree that allow the the
revenger z-- the members of the camp
servers to track them down locate them
and then take them the issue with this
is that it's picked up almost
immediately right off the bat when it
comes to Marvel that name Arita is not
the the avatar of death right it's not
her but the idea is she can possibly
lead them to to the avatar or something
along those lines the issue with all
this is that in the middle of it all
that's when the annihilators arrived and
the annihilators start unleashing all
kinds of different problems now here's
the cool thing is we get these little
cameos here in there right like you
basically get like the ravager version
of venom at the version of it and they
can't die and this venom of course is
well I guess kind of can die this venom
is more or less taken out by by Ron and
the accuser you get the ravager versions
of the x-men right so like the cancerous
versions of the x-men the funny thing
about this is that this version of the
x-men actually shows up in war of realms
the Imperial Guard but it's kind of a
quick little thing is it's not a great
big huge thing I mean it is to a degree
but seeing like seeing the x-men is not
nearly that interesting it's not what
you would think it would be but
essentially all these forces of Marvel
are dealt with quite readily by the
annihilators because again you're
talking about a vast amount of power
being used now remember these guys can't
truly die so what they do when they
destroy them is a more or less
incapacitate them and then ultimately
all these different foes will return the
problem with this and what really seems
to come to a head here is that
ultimately Marvel begins to pick up on
the fact that essentially Thanos was
killed inside of the cancerverse
and so him having the kind of connection
to the cancer verse that he does he
immediately realizes what's going on and
then says like the avatar of death the
reason why we can't find him is because
the avatar of death is in our universe
he's not here now so they basically say
like let's go like let's teleport away
so they end up teleporting away directly
to the cancerverse itself the fight
thing is that we saw phantoms die at the
hands of Drax to the story but remember
Santos can't die and so that this really
kind of answers the question what
happens what a person is banned from the
realm of mistress death and then
essentially dies through conventional
meats right like what happens to them
like what something like this when when
their body is totally disintegrated the
result is that their body reforms now
there's precedent for this and this
comes from the story oh really comes by
way of the story funeral for free from
Deadpool right so to sidetrack here for
a second Deadpool was ultimately cursed
with immortality by Thanos and salt
because of the fact that mistress death
was in love with Deadpool
and she was in love with Thanos right so
that was being angry about that cursed
odd Deadpool of immortality so that when
Deadpool was destroyed and all that was
left with his hand his body we grew from
his hand right so that's where this
really comes from this that kind of laid
the groundwork for this sort of
situation now it really kind of depends
on on who's writing the story when you
looked at fan o's having been Hearst
with immortality and then you have the
events of like the incursions and the
collapse of the multiverse when all that
came to an end in Thanos was
quote-unquote destroyed by by God king
Doom during the events of secret Wars he
didn't really die because he couldn't go
to the realm on mistress death but he
didn't reconstitute instead what ended
up happening is he was banished to a
realm that was basically oblivion it was
a place beyond the entirety of the
multiverse just this giant empty void is
really what it was and so because of
that when the events of all-new
all-different marvel took place and
phantoms returned during the Avengers
stories he literally broke out of that
realm that kind of giant void and then
showed up in the main Marvel Universe
right so it depends on who's writing the
story is it's the nature of comics
there's no hard and fast rule here it
just depends on what's going on and how
a particular writer wants to take things
in a particular direction but then I'll
show him back up here of course he's
pissed because of the fact that Drax
killed him so it's like okay that's the
kind of game you want to play then let's
play the game and he just totally
eradicated Drax the destroyer right just
totally annihilate this guy and destroys
him and so in the aftermath of that you
had the annihilators really kind of
grabbing those individuals who have been
taken by lord Marvel and when Lord
Marvel on them had taken off ultimately
when the annihilators were making their
escape
Lord Marvel quite literally pops in this
is one last thing and detonates the ship
blows up the ship seemingly killing
everybody on board but what is it going
on here is that with all the other
members of the team being here let's say
all the forces of Thanos all these guys
being back in this cancerverse their
nature their situation leads to the
arrival
the revenger x' ah really kind of the
the I guess the forward team being sent
by Marvel insofar as like war machine
and Hawkeye and Captain America as well
as Scarlet Witch herself now this is
where things get really interesting here
because with this massive battle that
breaks out with this massive battle
that's going on here what we end up
finding out is the Scarlet Witch is to a
degree kind of a traitor in the in the
sense that what took place here is the
Scarlet Witch was never really on the
side of all the various superheroes and
Wisconsin which gets there and finds
that that vision has basically been
destroyed then we end up finding out she
was a spy the entire time that when
Marvel had undergone the process of
warping all the superheroes in his
universe in the cancerverse
and then in turn you know basically
killed death and then brought into many
angled ones mid scarlet which had
essentially stood there as a kind of spy
of sorts and so that's why she ended up
leading these various field teams is
because what she was always trying to do
was try to find you know one try to find
a way to make contact with vision again
and then to report her findings and try
to find a way to work along or at least
you know serve her role alongside the
resistance and that's what's been going
on the entire time and so when this goes
down she literally destroys all the
other superheroes who were there like
all the other Avengers basically
incapacitates and destroys Alden at
least as best she can and then in turn
joins the the Guardians themselves now
of course they're hesitant right I mean
you got this chick who's basically like
a skewed warped bad guy but vision
chimes in and says she's been working
with the resistance since the very
beginning you can trust her everything
will be okay the reality of this is
because the betrayal of the Scarlet
Witch what's going to happen here the
fate that's going to be gonna be
bestowed upon her is that she'll be
taken by the many angled ones and
what'll end up happening is her soul
will be torn apart and it'll be it'll be
tortured and she'll experience pain
beyond imagining for the rest of
eternity right for all of existence it's
gonna be the worst possible fate that
she could ever experience right just
having her soul torn apart over and over
and over again but ultimately it's the
sacrifice she makes because in truth she
believes that what's going on here with
Marvel and everything taking place is
wrong and it's an inherently bad thing
and so what is up happening if she
basically says here's one final gambit
exhausting my powers doing what I can
I'm going to teleport all of you to the
realm of or the first and necropsy took
place the first instance of mistress
death being destroyed in this universe
the place they have to go to in order to
reverse the entire process at the same
time kind of a cool little thing here
sort of an explanation that in terms of
the annihilators in the various forces
you seem to be destroyed all that really
went
here is that window Vaughn himself and
and it really is this quantum bands of
sorts to kind of channel everybody's
power and they create a kind of cocoon
for themselves to basically safeguard
them and keep them alive right which is
well within the power of the the quantum
bands but the cool thing about this is
what's still going on on the front lines
and it's very easy to forget about that
with everything else taking place right
to forget about what's happening in the
front line of the fault in this giant
battle did in reality this Galactus
engine is still there and it's still
destroying these cosmic entities that
none of them really seem to be able to
stand a chance that most of the forces
that are there around half the forces of
all these various groups this part or
the Kree the the the forces of blast are
so on and so forth the Shiar they've all
basically been obliterated right half
their forces are pretty much gone and
they're fighting with really what
amounts to a skeleton crew is really all
this left
it's what little forces they can to
stave off against this massive threat
the cosmic entities some of them have
already fled right some of them have
already left and said I'm we can't fight
this like we can't win this war and so
what you end up getting is back on the
cancerverse itself you end up having
kind of this this location that's met by
by Thanos and all of his various forces
and the idea is okay let's fight this
conflict and let's see where this goes
and so ultimately when they arrived
there at this location they end up
finding that the place is kind of uh not
really living and it's not really dead
people are just kind of or at least
what's there is kind of in this sort of
state of limbo more or less it's kind of
the the strange scenario that goes on
not only that we also end up learning
that when Marvel finally shows up that
basically Thanos was the embodiment or
was the avatar of death in that universe
right so Thanos in that universe was
basically destroyed by Marvel and
presumably it worked out the way that
Thanos wanted it to I mean we'd have to
believe given the nature of Thanos that
he was okay with it right spending an
eternity with mistress death was
something that was highly you know
sought after by him and so the result is
that where you end up having the the
guardians or at least Nova who sits down
and sort of looks at this transmission
that was left behind by star-lord and
saying you know me and the guardians
would grab Thanos we took off to the
cancerverse we're gonna try to find a
way to undo all of this and he invites
Richard Ryder along
Richard Ryder ends up going to the cans
averse to fight alongside star-lord
essentially one last time and so this
conflict this this huge battle is pretty
hardcore right because literally they're
fighting to keep Thanos alive and
they're fighting to defend off against
these guys who really can't die right if
all these forces die then it'll
basically be the end of it all because
seemingly if Thanos can't hold all of
them off on his own so it's a pretty
huge gambit but what is it going on this
is this
one of the crazy things what is up
happening here is that in the middle of
this giant battle suddenly Dano stops
and Thanos says please give me the one
thing that I can have the power you guys
have in this universe is astronomical
because now you're backed by the many
angled one these these insanely powerful
artifacts she's insanely powerful
objects if in your universe you had the
means to kill the avatar of death
insofar as it bypassed the power of
mistress death then please do that grant
me the death that I seek kill me and so
ultimately Thanos ends up giving up
basically ends up releasing Marvel and
ultimately ends up bending the knee and
joining his side without being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you I new here to come this explain
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the rod poor if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
Bruce
[Music]